et on accueille notre invité du vendredi
à nîmes bourdais bonjour je vous êtes
membre du groupe 60 d'amnesty
international s'est ainsi 60 mais parce
que c'est au numéro du groupe de
versailles notamment et le groupe a
présenté ce mardi soir mardi 14 mai un
documentaire de show soit oppenheimer
qui s'appelle direct of killing est
littéralement l'acte de tuer ce sera au
cinéma le roxana versailles est ce que
vous nous dire quelques mots sur ce
documentaire alors c'est un film c'est à
la fois un documentaire est à la fois un
film d'acteur mais c'est un film très
particulier puisqu'il retrace et il
donne la parole à des bourreaux qui ont
exterminés pendant plusieurs années
d'économies de 500 mille à un million de
personnes à domicile
c'est à partir des effectivement c'est
qu'on donne la parole et ont d'habitude
nos zones visées ne sont pas condamnés
ah non non non qui continuent à vivre en
toute impunité
si sûr tout ça ce à quoi s'opposent en
politique je rappelle qu'à lyon en 1966
et depuis soixante-cinq
les bourreaux comme vous les appelez il
continue à vivre parmi la population
parmi les gens qui qu'ils ont traqué
parmi les familles de victimes qui n'ont
pas été reconnues et qui n'arrivent pas
à faire
affaire justice et c'est vraiment très
particulier parce que
jusqu'à présent
les
les victimes pouvaient s'exprimer mais
là elles ne peuvent pas parler puisque
elles sont toujours sous la crainte de
représailles
autant d'aléas voilà autant d'années à
andrest ça pose le problème de
l'impunité bien sûr comment est-ce qu'on
juge ces personnes et quelle est la
volonté des états de vouloir les juger
et vous savez comment je sois
oppenheimer a pu travailler sur ce
documentaire je présume que c'est assez
compliqué à la fois retrouver des
bourreaux à la fois les inciter à parler
pour sont du coup le monde entier ou en
tout cas beaucoup de gens vont découvrir
cette histoire tragique oui au départ
c'était pas sa volonté il faisait un
reportage sur des personnes qui y
travaillaient dans des champs ou et puis
il s'est aperçu qu
il avait des conditions de vie qui était
très difficile qui ne pouvait pas monter
deux syndicats qui pouvait pas se
défendre parce qu'ils étaient toujours
sous la menace de ses bourreaux et c'est
comme ça ça l'a énormément surpris parce
que autant d'années après la justice n'a
pas été faite et c'est comme ça qu'il a
pu rencontrer ces personnes là et il
s'est dit je vais leur donner la parole
justement pour pour essayer de
comprendre le processus parce que au
niveau humain s'est très ça nous
interpelle quand même se dire comment
est ce que des personnes
qui sont comme tout le monde au départ
comment est-ce qu'on devient bourreau et
comment est ce que il n'y a pas de de
remords renie pas du tout enfin c'est
c'est vraiment très surprenant mondiale
taking donc je le dis mardi 14 mai à
20h30 au cinéma le rex un suivi d'un
débat il a déjà animé par par plusieurs
personnes alors plusieurs personnes il
ya donc daniel brunier qui est
responsable
de la section indonésie à paris c'est
elle qui est responsable de toutes les
actions qui sont faites sur ce pays et
puis francis perrin qui est un ancien
président d'amnesty international qui
sera là également pour parler surtout au
niveau de l'impunité et des moyens
maintenant qu'ils ont été mis en oeuvre
pour
pour arriver à
combattre cette impunité et puis il ya
eu des avancées il ya des procès
maintenant internationaux importants et
donc l'ajout d'un documentaire qui
pourrait faire avancer les choses
d'après vous un je le pense oui oui oui
parce que justement il repose la
question
de la volonté du gouvernement indonésien
régulièrement un essai d'un simple
organise comme ça enfin votre groupe
soit de versailles ainsi régulièrement
des diffusions comme ça depuis nous à
versailles nous organisons en moyenne à
peu près une diffusion tous les deux
mois pour avec en partenariat avec
l'association culture et cinéma qui les
analyse
et donc eu s'occupe de la programmation
de la salle culture et cinéma ou roxane
et puis de temps en temps donc
on travaille en partenariat pour
présenter des films qui incite au débat
et qui touche les problématiques
amnistie alors avant de continuer de
parler avec vous vous allez nous parler
de votre action à vous si nous expliquer
comment vous avez intégré ce groupe à
michel et pourquoi il ya de nombreuses
années mais je vous propose avoir de
regarder la bande annonce justement du
documentaire de ce soit oppenheimer les
acteurs feeling
ou pas
il est nul
il
et au-delà
mais d'ici là les japonais
alors ma vie tourne au final
taux
ravalomanana
on verra
créée par sarah des anomalies
il a
déclaré
et a
diffusé le 10 avril à découvrir donc
partie soir
on entend le mois les graisses enfin ça
fait
un sentiment un petit peu un petit peu
bizarre vous animerez vous êtes membre
d'amnesty international depuis 1990 mais
un peu ce qui vous a donné envie
d'intégrer amnesty y avait une cause en
particulier vous avez conflit soutenir à
cette époque là bas c'est à dire que je
voulais faire quelque chose participer
quand même
à une
la solidarité entre entre les personnes
et puis
j'étais assez sensible aux droits des
enfants
à l'injustice et puis à des événements
qui se passait dans le monde et et c'est
vrai qu'à chaque fois on se pose la
question comment qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire comment comment on peut intervenir
et vous qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ce
que vous avez l'impression vous depuis
90 vous êtes membre du contexte
international à versailles est-ce que
vous avez l'impression que les choses
ont évolué positivement
ou encore beaucoup de choses qui sont
tus saint lô le saint-louis bien c'est
ce que malgré tout il y avait vu ils
sont positives je rappelle que l'année
dernière c'était 50-50 et cinq
commerçants voient la dame est ici donc
c'est quand même une association qui
dure depuis longtemps et qui qui a
maintenant une notoriété auprès des
des autorités est il quand on parle d'
amnistie enfin ça représente quelque
chose et alors que quand amnistie a été
créé en 1961 on parlait pas des droits
de l'homme s'était pas du tout dans la
problématique des dirigeants politiques
maintenant
on va peut-être plus maintenant qu'à mon
avis plus bien sûr bien sûr il ya et
puis il ya des avancées même si
quelquefois on a l'impression que tout
ce qu'on a gagné il faut continuer à
défendre où il faut remettre encore son
ouvrage mais
il y à des avancées positives il ya des
hauts niveaux de l'abolition de la peine
de mort
il ya de plus en plus de pays qui sont
abolitionnistes
ne serait-ce que aux états unis qui est
un des derniers bastions des grands pays
démocratiques qui continuent à pratiquer
la peine de mort on voit que les
mentalités évoluent et il y aura
prochainement d'ailleurs un texte qui
sera voté à l'onu sur le contrôle des
armes voilà sur le contrôle des armes
pour depuis
plusieurs années déjà 4 5 ans les
associations agissent pour qu'il y ait
un contrôle de la circulation des armes
parce que c'est ce qui favorise les
conflits armés en afrique et donc donc
les choses diable et il ya des bonnes
choses merci donc à lebron est revenu
sur le plateau du 7-8 week end je
rappelle juste que votre groupe
intervient si on veut vous rencontrer
une fois par mois sur le marché de
versailles je peux déjà annoncer aussi
un complément ce qu'a lieu le 8 mars le
ouija la mairie allait consacrer à la
colombie et puis vous participerez c'est
plus long mais je le dis quand même oui
paris versailles le 29 septembre wallace
ainsi à venir une chose mais nous
expulser on peut appeler ça du brésil
devrait pas accueillir la coupe du monde
de full et comme il faisait grand
chantier qui se passe c'est des gens qui
sont en ce moment on le sait pas on le
sera grâce à vous le 29 septembre lors
du paris versailles parce qu'il y aura
des voies l'allergie les ports heures
pour apporter le tee shirt pantalon
baissé c'est beaucoup et apporter un
soutien à tous les gens qui se battent
partout dans le monde merci vous connais
bon d'être sûr pas tout de suite